what's a call that would surprise me you  don't have to tell me about the  conversation but who's someone who  called you and you were surprised they  took offense by something you said man  God Rest in Peace Kobe I'm trying to  think that was so long ago  but that was that was really one of the  funniest nights of my life  because I get back to the hotel  and it's like 2 30.  and we text each other probably another  10 15 times well his texts were like  it cursing me out  I'm like yo man I explained to you why I  said what I said no ifs and well I just  and then like I said when we saw each  other next year he said yo man you know  what you were right and that's the thing  I remind about Kobe he says Chuck you  was right and I was wrong I said yo man  I love you you were wrong that night  I'm not trying to these kids today  counsel anybody